As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal.
作为7-Eleven的脆皮鸡三明治，人们总说我声音很大。我心想，是啊，我知道。我很脆。难道你指望我耳语吗？如果你想要安静，去喝点汤反思一下吧。我是说，我知道我很难搞。我大胆，我多汁。给我撒点酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一顿完整的大餐。
And with seven rewards, I'm just $4. Quiet. No. Krispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 36-2326, participating stores only while supplies lastly out for full terms. Sleading news stories, propaganda, conspiracy theories. If you go online, turn on your TV, or even talk to your friends and neighbors, you're eventually going to encounter some type of misinformation.
有了7-Eleven的奖励计划，我只要4美元。安静？不。脆皮、多汁、只要4美元？非常可以。仅限7-Eleven。详情请见36-2326，仅限参与活动的门店，售完即止，完整条款请见官网。耸人听闻的新闻报道、宣传、阴谋论。如果你上网、打开电视，甚至与朋友和邻居交谈，你最终都会遇到某种形式的错误信息。
Misinformation has always been with us, but with the rise of social media, it can now spread farther and faster than ever, threatening people's health and well-being, their trust in institutions, and perhaps even democracy itself. In the face of these threats, psychologists and other researchers are working to develop new ways to help people better separate truth from falsehood, arm themselves against misinformation, and understand when they're being manipulated. So what is misinformation and why does it spread so fast? How much misinformation are people exposed to on a regular basis? Does misinformation spread faster than truth? What can people do to show up their psychological defenses against it? What is the role of schools in educating students about misinformation? How is AI changing the landscape of misinformation and what role should social media platforms play in combating it?
错误信息一直伴随着我们，但随着社交媒体的兴起，它现在可以比以往任何时候都传播得更远、更快，威胁着人们的健康和福祉、对机构的信任，甚至可能威胁到民主本身。面对这些威胁，心理学家和其他研究人员正在努力开发新方法，帮助人们更好地分辨真伪，武装自己以抵御错误信息，并了解自己何时受到操纵。那么，什么是错误信息？为什么它传播得如此之快？人们经常接触到多少错误信息？错误信息的传播速度比真相快吗？人们可以做些什么来加强心理防御？学校在教育学生识别错误信息方面扮演什么角色？人工智能如何改变错误信息的格局？社交媒体平台在打击错误信息方面应该发挥什么作用？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Sander Vanderlinden, a professor of social psychology and society. at the University of Cambridge in the UK. His research centers around human judgment and decision making, in particular how people are influenced by misinformation and how they can learn to resist it. He's published more than 150 scientific papers
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是英国剑桥大学社会心理学与社会学教授桑德·范德林登博士。他的研究集中在人类判断和决策上，特别是人们如何受到错误信息的影响以及如何学会抵御它。他发表了150多篇科学论文，
and his work is regularly featured in the popular media, including the New York Times, the BBC, CNN, and Time magazine to name just a few. Dr. van der Linden also consults about his research for the public, industry, and government organizations, including with institutions such as the World Health Organization, the National Academy of Sciences, and Google. His book, Full Proof, Why Misinformation Infects Our Minds and How to Build Immunity, was published in April.
他的工作经常出现在大众媒体上，包括《纽约时报》、BBC、CNN和《时代》杂志等等。范德林登博士还为公众、行业和政府组织提供研究咨询，包括世界卫生组织、美国国家科学院和谷歌等机构。他的书《万无一失：错误信息为何感染我们的思想以及如何建立免疫力》于四月出版。
Finally, Dr. Vanderlinden led the team that produced a report released this month by APA called Using Psychological Science to Understand and Fight Health Misinformation, an APA Consensus Statement. Dr. Vanderlinden, thank you for joining me today. Thanks so much for having me on. In the APA report I just mentioned, misinformation is defined as any information that is demonstrably false or otherwise misleading,
最后，范德林登博士领导的团队撰写了一份报告，该报告于本月由美国心理学会（APA）发布，题为《利用心理科学理解和打击健康错误信息：APA共识声明》。范德林登博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢邀请我。在我刚才提到的APA报告中，错误信息被定义为任何明显虚假或具有误导性的信息，
regardless of its source or intention. Can you dig into that for us? Why are we being bombarded with misinformation and how is misinformation different from disinformation? Yeah, so we actually spend a lot of time talking about how to define misinformation. And, you know, One of the elements that comes up is that the scope and the problem of misinformation is, in part,
无论其来源或意图如何。您能为我们深入剖析一下吗？为什么我们会被错误信息轰炸？错误信息与虚假信息（disinformation）有何不同？是的，我们确实花了很多时间讨论如何定义错误信息。你知道，其中一个要素是，错误信息的范围和问题在一定程度上，
determined by how we define it. So, for example, you know, if we define misinformation as only purely fabricated information, then if you look at the stats on that, that's, you know, not a huge part of most people's media diet. I mean, it comes up, you know, thinking about manipulated images during the recent Israel-Gaza conflict, for example, it comes up. But, you know, it's not every day. But if you change that definition to include half-truths, biased narratives, misleading argumentation, logical fallacies, presenting things out of context. And so that all falls under the category of misleading information, then all of the sudden misinformation becomes a much bigger problem and takes up a much bigger chunk of people's media diet.
取决于我们如何定义它。例如，如果我们仅将错误信息定义为纯粹捏造的信息，那么如果你查看相关统计数据，你会发现这在大多数人的媒体消费中占比并不大。我的意思是，它确实会出现，比如最近以色列-加沙冲突期间被操纵的图像，它确实会出现。但它并非每天都有。但如果你改变定义，将半真半假、有偏见的叙述、误导性论证、逻辑谬误、断章取义等内容包括在内，那么所有这些都属于误导性信息的范畴，突然之间，错误信息就成了一个大得多的问题，占据了人们媒体消费中更大的一部分。
And so that's why we tried to arrive at a consensus in terms of what misinformation is. And we decided that it's both. It's both outrightly false information as well as misleading information. And of course, the question you can ask is what's the difference between disinformation and misinformation? Now, disinformation is misinformation coupled with some psychological intention to explicitly deceive or harm other people. And the reason why we defined it as misinformation being independent of intent is because intent is actually, difficult to prove in a legal sense. So they have been documented disinformation campaigns.
这就是为什么我们试图就什么是错误信息达成共识。我们决定它两者皆是。它既包括完全虚假的信息，也包括误导性的信息。当然，你可以问，虚假信息（disinformation）和错误信息（misinformation）有什么区别？虚假信息是错误信息加上某种明确欺骗或伤害他人的心理意图。我们将其定义为与意图无关的错误信息，是因为在法律意义上，意图实际上很难证明。所以确实有记录在案的虚假信息运动。
For example, from the tobacco industry, who, you know, a court in the United States ruled that they have been deceiving the public intentionally for over 50 years between the link between smoking and disease. So that's an example of disinformation. But it's not always so easy to tell what people's intentions are. And that's why we refer to it as misinformation in the sense of being conservative. about what we know. So how big a problem is the spread of misinformation?
例如，烟草行业，美国一家法院裁定，他们在吸烟与疾病之间的联系上故意欺骗公众超过50年。这就是虚假信息的一个例子。但要判断人们的意图并不总是那么容易。这就是为什么我们称之为错误信息，这在了解我们所知的内容方面比较保守。那么错误信息的传播有多严重？
Is there any way to quantify how much misinformation people are being exposed to every day? Yeah. So, you know, as I said, it highly depends on your definition. So if you assume that the definition is just purely fabricated information, then, you know, you might actually just be talking about, you know, one or a couple percent of people's overall media diet. If you're talking about misleading information, then maybe we're talking about, you know, up to 20% of people's media diet. It's also incredibly diverse. So for some people, you know, depending on the new sources that they visit, they don't see much misinformation.
有没有办法量化人们每天接触到多少错误信息？是的，正如我所说，这很大程度上取决于你的定义。如果你假设定义仅是纯粹捏造的信息，那么你可能实际上只是在谈论人们整体媒体消费的百分之一或几个百分点。如果你谈论的是误导性信息，那么我们谈论的可能是人们媒体消费的20%。它也非常多样化。对于一些人来说，根据他们访问的新闻来源，他们看不到太多错误信息。
But for a smaller group of people, they're embroiled in it. I mean, they're basically stuck in an online echo chamber and are continuously bombarded by misinformation. You know, people who get most of their news from social media, for example, see much more misinformation than people who don't primarily get their news from social media. That's not to say that there's no misinformation on, let's say, cable news. But it, you know, so it depends. And it's difficult to quantify. And, you know, I'll say that we did our best in the report to look at these estimates and say, well, you know, I can range anywhere from one to 20 percent depending on people's circumstances, visual disinformation is a hugely underestimated factor.
但对于一小部分人来说，他们深陷其中。我的意思是，他们基本上被困在网络回声室里，不断受到错误信息的轰炸。例如，那些主要从社交媒体获取新闻的人，比那些不主要从社交媒体获取新闻的人看到更多的错误信息。这并不是说有线电视新闻上没有错误信息。但它确实取决于具体情况。而且很难量化。我会说，我们在报告中尽了最大努力来查看这些估计，并说，嗯，根据人们的情况，范围可能从1%到20%不等。视觉虚假信息是一个被严重低估的因素。
So, you know, much of what's misleading online are also manipulated images, which are often not counted, but actually form a large part of what it is that people see. But most importantly, and I think this is the point that, that is my, you know, to some extent, my personal take, but I think also generally relevant is that we don't actually have good ways of integrating all of the different ways in the, which people are exposed to misinformation. So if you read a typical study, and this is what we have to do for the consensus report, you know, it's based on how much misinformation you saw on Twitter during, let's say, an election.
所以，网上很多误导性内容也是被操纵的图像，这些图像通常没有被统计在内，但实际上构成了人们所见内容的一大部分。但最重要的是，我认为这一点——在某种程度上是我个人的看法，但我认为也具有普遍相关性——是我们实际上没有好的方法来整合人们接触错误信息的所有不同方式。所以如果你读一篇典型的研究，这也是我们为共识报告所必须做的，它是基于你在选举期间在推特上看到了多少错误信息。
But, you know, is Twitter the only platform that you're on? You're not only on Twitter. You might be on Facebook. You might be on Twitter. You might be on TikTok. You're using WhatsApp. You talk to your neighbors. You watch cable TV.
但是，推特是你使用的唯一平台吗？你不仅仅在使用推特。你可能在使用脸书。你可能在使用推特。你可能在使用TikTok。你在使用WhatsApp。你和邻居交谈。你看有线电视。
You read newspapers. How do you quantify for a given individual all of the misinformation that's coming at them through all of these various channels. I mean, we don't have the capacity or the tools to do that efficiently at the moment. So I think we're probably underestimating how much misinformation people are really exposed to. So that's, you know, that's where we're currently at. But the quantified estimates that we do have often coming from single platforms and looking at, let's say, browsing data or things like that, suggests that there is, you know, a lot of variation,
你读报纸。你如何为一个特定的人量化通过所有这些不同渠道向他们涌来的所有错误信息？我的意思是，我们目前没有能力或工具来有效地做到这一点。所以我认为我们可能低估了人们真正接触到的错误信息量。这就是我们目前的处境。但我们确实拥有的量化估计通常来自单一平台，并查看浏览数据之类的内容，这表明存在很多差异，
but it's not a holistic picture. I mentioned in the intro that one of the places that you consult to is Google. And I'm just wondering how well are these platforms adapting to what's happening on them with miss and disinformation? Are they really invested in curbing it? I think it, you know, there's a, it ebbs and flows, you know, depending on, A, how much people demanded and how much discussion. there is of it. And so, for example, there were times during an election and during a pandemic that these companies feel some incentive to actually monitor things very closely, to do fact-checking, to maybe even have preemptive measures in place. But then at other times, you know, they seem
但这并不是一个全面的图景。我在介绍中提到，你咨询的机构之一是谷歌。我很好奇这些平台在适应它们上面发生的错误信息和虚假信息方面做得如何？它们真的投入精力去遏制它吗？我认为，这取决于人们的需求程度以及对此的讨论程度。例如，在选举期间和疫情期间，这些公司确实感到有动力去非常密切地监控事物，进行事实核查，甚至可能采取预防措施。但在其他时候，它们似乎
quite lax. So, for example, a lot of these companies have been actually backsliding and following Musk's example of actually doing less and less, firing the content moderators, getting rid of trust and safety teams, and not even taking down content anymore. There's a lot of hesitation. So just to contextualize this for people, during a pandemic, there were quite direct with, for example, taking down harmful content on COVID-19 on election fraud. And that is because, yeah, sure, there's free speech, but there are exceptions to free speech. And when the exceptions violate user policy, they can take things down.
相当松懈。例如，许多这些公司实际上一直在倒退，效仿马斯克的做法，做得越来越少，解雇内容审核员，裁撤信任与安全团队，甚至不再删除内容。有很多犹豫。为了让人们了解背景，在疫情期间，它们在删除有关新冠肺炎和选举舞弊的有害内容方面非常直接。这是因为，是的，确实有言论自由，但言论自由是有例外的。当例外情况违反用户政策时，它们可以删除内容。
And that's usually done when there's direct harm to people. So, for example, if you're spreading harmful medical advice or if you're undermining the democratic process and so on. But for all of the other stuff, it's often just labeled as opinion. People are expressing their opinions, right? There's no direct harm that is easily identifiable. And so they leave it up. And now we're seeing that they're leaving up deepfakes created during political campaigns. I mean, they have expressly said now that they're no longer taking down fraudulent claims about the previous election, right?
这通常是在对人们造成直接伤害时才会这样做。例如，如果你在传播有害的医疗建议，或者如果你在破坏民主进程等等。但对于所有其他内容，它通常只是被贴上“观点”的标签。人们在表达他们的观点，对吧？没有容易识别的直接伤害。所以它们就保留了这些内容。现在我们看到它们保留了政治竞选期间创建的深度伪造内容。我的意思是，它们现在明确表示不再删除关于上次选举的欺诈性声明，对吧？
Sort of saying, oh, you know, all of the stuff about election fraud, you know, the false conspiracy, we're going to leave that up now and we're going to stop taking that down. So unfortunately, you know, sometimes it's, it's, you know, one step forward, two steps backward. And that's been the rhythm that I've seen over a longer period of time. So, you know, we work with these companies to implement solutions. Some of them, like Google, have been extremely receptive to media literacy education, empowering people to spot misinformation on the platform, funding, research, testing it on their platforms. But then when it comes to the final step of wide implementation and pushing things, you know, to the next level in terms of actually making this an integral part of their policies, that's often where you see the hesitation. And when the political climate is not conducive, this hesitation is amplified. So in the United States, right, there are lawsuits at the moment.
就像是说，哦，关于选举舞弊的所有那些虚假阴谋论，我们现在要保留它们，我们不再删除它们了。所以不幸的是，有时是前进一步，后退两步。这就是我在很长一段时间内看到的节奏。所以，我们与这些公司合作实施解决方案。其中一些，比如谷歌，对媒体素养教育非常接受，赋能人们在平台上识别错误信息，资助研究，并在其平台上进行测试。但当涉及到广泛实施和将事情推向下一个阶段，即真正将其作为其政策不可或缺的一部分时，这往往就是你看到犹豫的地方。当政治气候不利时，这种犹豫就会被放大。所以在美国，目前有诉讼。
So a lot of these companies, right, for people who don't know, you know, there are ongoing lawsuits against the Biden administration for funding research on misinformation, and that somehow it's targeting, you know, one side of the political spectrum and that there's more censoring going on. So it's become politicized, which has a chilling effect on not only what the government is doing, but on what all of these social media companies are doing, which is very little at the moment. Let me ask a really basic question, which is why is it so easy for us to fall prey to misinformation? What are the factors that make us vulnerable to it? Yeah, and so sometimes I think it's easy for people to sort of think of the individual that is susceptible to misinformation.
所以很多这些公司，对于不知道的人来说，目前有针对拜登政府资助错误信息研究的诉讼，认为这在某种程度上针对政治光谱的一方，并且存在更多的审查。所以它已经政治化了，这不仅对政府正在做的事情产生了寒蝉效应，而且对所有这些社交媒体公司正在做的事情也产生了寒蝉效应，目前它们做得很少。让我问一个非常基本的问题，为什么我们如此容易成为错误信息的牺牲品？哪些因素使我们容易受到它的影响？是的，有时我认为人们很容易想到容易受到错误信息影响的个人。
People tend to think, oh, it's not me. It's some other person, and they have kind of ideas about whom that person might, might be. But in fact, if you look at the research, you know, there's some some good research and very solid research on the cognitive and social elements that really make us all vulnerable to misinformation. And some of these factors include what we call fluency. So fluency is about the speed with which you process information. And so we know that we process repeated claims faster than non-repeated claims. And so misinformation producers can use that to their advantage, right? if they keep lying and keep saying false statements, we process it faster, so more fluently.
人们倾向于认为，哦，那不是我。那是别人，他们对那个人可能是谁有一些想法。但事实上，如果你看研究，关于认知和社会因素确实使我们所有人都容易受到错误信息的影响，有一些很好的研究。其中一些因素包括我们所说的“流畅性”。流畅性是指你处理信息的速度。我们知道，我们处理重复声明的速度比非重复声明快。因此，错误信息生产者可以利用这一点，对吧？如果他们不断撒谎并不断陈述虚假陈述，我们处理它的速度就更快，因此更流畅。
It feels more familiar. Research shows that people find it less unethical over time to share false things that they've heard over and over again because you're getting used to it, right? It also feels more true. And so then it's where you get what we call illusory truth effects. And so illusory truth is when people, you know, have the illusion that something is true because simply they've heard it before. We know that once people are exposed to misinformation,
它感觉更熟悉。研究表明，人们随着时间的推移会觉得分享他们反复听到的虚假内容不那么不道德，因为你习惯了，对吧？它也感觉更真实。这就是我们所说的“虚幻真理效应”。虚幻真理是指人们仅仅因为以前听过某件事，就产生了一种它是真实的错觉。我们知道，一旦人们接触到错误信息，
it lingers in our memory. This is what we call the continued influence of misinformation. And so even when people acknowledge having seen a correction, you know, once you're exposed, once it integrates itself in your memory and connects with other things that you know, it kind of makes friends, right, if you think of your memory as a social network, very difficult to then eliminate it completely. And so that's what we call the continued influence of misinformation. And so, you know, those things are general factors about how the brain works that
它就会留在我们的记忆中。这就是我们所说的“错误信息的持续影响”。所以即使人们承认看到了更正，一旦你接触到它，一旦它整合到你的记忆中并与你所知道的其他事物联系起来，它就会“交朋友”，对吧？如果你把你的记忆想象成一个社交网络，那么要完全消除它就非常困难。这就是我们所说的错误信息的持续影响。所以，这些关于大脑如何运作的一般因素，
that makes everyone susceptible. And then, yeah, if you want to craft a more specific profile, you know, people are more politically extreme, people who spend a lot of time on social media, people who engage in less analytic or deliberative thinking, people who are low on trust and high in paranoia, people who've had trauma in their childhood. So those are all factors that are associated with being more, you know, quote-unquote, vulnerable to misinformation. Now, in your work, you've made the analogy that misinformation spreads like a virus.
使每个人都容易受到影响。然后，如果你想制定一个更具体的特征，你知道，政治立场更极端的人，在社交媒体上花费大量时间的人，进行较少分析性或审慎思考的人，信任度低且偏执程度高的人，童年时期受过创伤的人。所以这些都是与更容易受到错误信息影响相关的因素。现在，在你的工作中，你做了一个比喻，说错误信息像病毒一样传播。
How literally should we take that analogy? Yeah. I think it's good to, you know, to have discussions about this. I mean, obviously, the infodemic is kind of a play on words, right? It's meant to sort of signal that it's not just a pandemic of a literal virus, but also a pandemic of information, having too much information, especially false information. But for me, and in the book, what I really try to do is say, look, this isn't just a cute sort of analogy to give people a frame of reference for thinking about this.
我们应该多字面地理解这个比喻？是的。我认为进行这方面的讨论是好的。我的意思是，显然，“信息疫情”（infodemic）是一种文字游戏，对吧？它旨在表明这不仅是字面意义上的病毒大流行，也是信息的大流行，拥有太多的信息，尤其是虚假信息。但对我来说，在书中，我真正试图做的是说，看，这不仅仅是一个给人们提供参考框架来思考这个问题的可爱比喻。
I mean, it is quite literal in the sense that we use models from epidemiology, such as the susceptible, infected, recovered model, which is called a sur model. So, you know, in a population, you have people who are susceptible to a virus that become infected and at some point they recover, you have models of dynamic social transmission, right? So how do people transmit a virus and you can model that? But it turns out you can use the same models more or less unchanged to study the diffusion of misinformation in social networks. And misinformation behaves much like a virus if you look at these models. And so in a simplistic version of this model, people are the nodes in the network, right?
我的意思是，它在某种意义上是相当字面的，因为我们使用了流行病学模型，例如“易感-感染-康复”模型，称为SIR模型。所以，在一个群体中，你有容易感染病毒的人，他们被感染，在某个时候他们康复了，你有动态社会传播模型，对吧？所以人们如何传播病毒，你可以对其进行建模。但事实证明，你可以使用基本相同的模型来研究错误信息在社交网络中的扩散。如果你看这些模型，错误信息表现得就像病毒一样。在这个模型的简化版本中，人是网络中的节点，对吧？
And so you come in contact through a link with somebody else and they share misinformation with you. So you become infected and activated and then you share it with other people. And then we can actually predict how far the misinformation will travel or how many people are exposed. And you can sort of think about how this diffuses in a network. And it's a very useful framework in a public health sort of sense to think about this idea. Now, critics might say, okay, but it's, you know, the simple contagion model of disease isn't exactly, you know, how it works with people. because people are more complex. And I think that's true, but you can make the model slightly more complex.
所以你通过链接与其他人接触，他们与你分享错误信息。所以你被感染并被激活，然后你与其他人分享它。然后我们实际上可以预测错误信息会传播多远，或者有多少人接触到它。你可以思考它如何在网络中扩散。在公共卫生的意义上，这是一个非常有用的思考这个想法的框架。现在，批评者可能会说，好吧，但简单的疾病传染模型并不完全是人们的工作方式，因为人更复杂。我认为这是真的，但你可以让模型稍微复杂一点。
You know, sometimes you need to be exposed repeatedly to misinformation before you accept it and spread it to other people. It's kind of like, you know, if somebody sneezes on you, you know, and say you're not going to get COVID 100% right, every time. Right, maybe you need to be sneezed on multiple times. And so, and so, you know, you can develop it in a similar way. And there are some slight differences. So, you know, these public health models and disease, it's often about random variation.
有时你需要反复接触错误信息才能接受它并将其传播给其他人。这有点像，如果有人对你打喷嚏，你并不会每次都100%感染新冠，对吧？也许你需要被多次喷嚏喷到。所以，你可以以类似的方式开发它。并且有一些细微的差别。所以，这些公共卫生模型和疾病，通常是关于随机变异的。
But the way people spread information isn't always random. It can be intentional. And that's where you get into some interesting deviations. So when people deliberately spread misinformation for, let's say, political purposes, that's where you have some interesting exceptions. But overall, I think it's quite literal and kind of a useful framework. And that, of course, also leads to the idea that, well, if it spreads like a virus, maybe we can vaccinate people. Right. And so let's talk about that. How do you inoculate people against fake news, misinformation, disinformation? What do you do? Yeah. So again, it's premised on the vaccination metaphor, more or less exactly. So just as vaccines introduce a weakened or inactivated strain of a virus into the body to try to trigger the production of antibodies, right, to help confer resistance against future infection, it turns out you can do the same with a human brain.
但人们传播信息的方式并不总是随机的。它可能是故意的。这就是你进入一些有趣的偏差的地方。所以当人们为了政治目的故意传播错误信息时，这就是你有一些有趣例外的地方。但总的来说，我认为它相当字面，是一种有用的框架。当然，这也引出了一个想法，即如果它像病毒一样传播，也许我们可以给人们接种疫苗。对。所以让我们谈谈那个。你如何给人们接种疫苗以抵御假新闻、错误信息、虚假信息？你做什么？是的。所以同样，它或多或少完全基于疫苗接种的隐喻。就像疫苗将减毒或灭活的病毒株引入体内以试图触发抗体的产生，以帮助赋予对未来感染的抵抗力一样，事实证明你也可以对人类大脑做同样的事情。
amtively exposing people to a weak dose of misinformation or the strategies used to produce misinformation. And by refuting and deconstructing those in advance, people can build up cognitive or mental antibodies and become more resistant to it in the future. And it should be specific. Sometimes people misinterpret this as exposing people to a weak dose of misinformation. That's only part of it, right? You also need to actually pre-bunk it and deconstruct it. And we use the term pre-bunking because it's easier for people to understand than inoculation sometimes and sort of to signal that it's the opposite of debunking. Because debunking information, even though it's important and effective in partially reducing how much people rely on information,
主动让人们接触弱剂量的错误信息或用于制造错误信息的策略。通过提前反驳和解构这些策略，人们可以建立认知或心理抗体，并在未来变得更具抵抗力。它应该是具体的。有时人们会误解这一点，认为这是让人们接触弱剂量的错误信息。那只是其中的一部分，对吧？你还需要实际地预先反驳（pre-bunk）和解构它。我们使用“预先反驳”这个词，因为有时它比“接种”更容易让人们理解，并且可以表明它是“反驳”（debunking）的对立面。因为反驳信息，尽管它在部分减少人们对信息的依赖方面很重要且有效，
you know, there's a consensus that obviously it's much harder to unring a bell, right? And so if you can, there is value in this idea of pre-bunking. We're just to sort of build preemptive resilience through exposure to weakens. doses of misinformation and showing people the tricks of disinformation and how it's produced in advance. And it's quite different from fact checking, right? So instead of giving people facts, you give them a weakened dose of the disinformation or misinformation, but then you also show people why and how it works so that they have
有一种共识是，显然“覆水难收”，对吧？所以如果可以的话，预先反驳的想法是有价值的。我们只是通过接触弱剂量的错误信息来建立先发制人的韧性，并提前向人们展示虚假信息的技巧以及它是如何产生的。它与事实核查非常不同，对吧？所以你不是给人们事实，而是给他们弱剂量的虚假信息或错误信息，但你同时也向人们展示它为什么以及如何运作，这样他们就有
the tools to resist it in the future. Right. So to carry the metaphor even further with a physical vaccine, the goal is usually to reach herd immunity where so many people are protected that the virus is no longer able to spread. Is it possible to reach herd immunity against misinformation? I think so. And just to give people some context, right, that I think we have to be realistic about the psychological vaccine analogy. So if we, people ask me a couple of questions, like, okay, what's the level of immunity? And, you know, to what extent, like give me a
了在未来抵御它的工具。对。所以为了进一步推进这个隐喻，对于物理疫苗，目标通常是达到群体免疫，即有足够多的人受到保护，以至于病毒无法再传播。有可能达到针对错误信息的群体免疫吗？我认为可以。为了给人们一些背景，我认为我们必须对心理疫苗的类比保持现实。所以如果人们问我几个问题，比如，好的，免疫水平是多少？而且，你能在多大程度上给我一个
a practical example of how this actually works, right? And so just to start with the second one, so Twitter before Musk, right, way before Musk, Twitter implemented some of this research and was pre-bunking during the election. And what they did was they forewarned people. So they send a message to the top of people's feed saying, be warned, you might see some misinformation about the election on the platform. This is to stimulate the psychological immune system. So make sure it's not sleeping, right?
实际的例子说明这是如何运作的，对吧？所以先从第二个开始，推特在马斯克之前，远在马斯克之前，推特实施了一些这项研究，并在选举期间进行了预先反驳。他们所做的是预先警告人们。所以他们在人们信息流的顶部发送了一条消息，说：请注意，你可能会在平台上看到一些关于选举的错误信息。这是为了刺激心理免疫系统。所以确保它没有在睡觉，对吧？
Wake people up into a more deliberative mode of processing. And then comes to pre-bunk and they said, look, you might see some, you know, funny stories or some false information that would suggest that voting by mail increases election fraud. However, you should know that all election experts basically agree that voting by mail is safe. And here are some authoritative resources if you want to arm yourself and learn more. And that's kind of what the pre-bunk is. Now, the question is, you know, what does that to people in terms of resilience?
唤醒人们进入更审慎的处理模式。然后进行预先反驳，他们说，看，你可能会看到一些有趣的报道或一些虚假信息，暗示邮寄投票会增加选举舞弊。然而，你应该知道，所有选举专家基本上都同意邮寄投票是安全的。如果你想武装自己并了解更多信息，这里有一些权威资源。这就是预先反驳。现在的问题是，这对人们的韧性有什么影响？
So, you know, if you come into my lab and I give you a 20-minute simulation in one of our special social media simulations. And, you know, I might boost your immunity by 60%, right? So that's quite good. That's like a flu job. But now if we transition from lab research and psychology to the real world, you know, typically we find, for example, with videos on YouTube, you know, and those annoying ads that you can't skip, that's where the pre-bunk could go.
所以，如果你来到我的实验室，我在我们特殊的社交媒体模拟中给你一个20分钟的模拟。我可能会将你的免疫力提高60%，对吧？这相当不错。这就像流感疫苗。但现在如果我们从实验室研究和心理学转向现实世界，通常我们发现，例如在YouTube的视频中，以及那些你无法跳过的烦人广告中，那就是预先反驳可以去的地方。
Yeah. If you have 30 seconds with people, maybe we're boosting you by 10% now. Right? So that's, you know, people have limited attention. they're in the world, they're distracted. It's a short message. So now we go from 60 to 10%. So skeptical colleagues would say, I don't know,
是的。如果你有30秒的时间与人们交流，也许我们现在将你的免疫力提高了10%。对吧？所以人们的注意力有限，他们在现实世界中，他们分心了。这是一个简短的信息。所以现在我们从60%降到了10%。持怀疑态度的同事会说，我不知道，
would people buy a vaccine at 10% efficacy? But I think that's where the herd immunity comes in, right? And so also for social media companies, right? The gist is actually that, you know, when companies play ads, you know, it's all about small effects, right? Brand recognition, they pay millions for 1% increase in recognition of a brand. So if we can do that for science and say, look, we run a 30, second video ad campaign and we can boost people by their immunity by 10% and then scale that
人们会购买10%有效性的疫苗吗？但我认为这就是群体免疫发挥作用的地方，对吧？对于社交媒体公司来说，要点实际上是，当公司投放广告时，这都是关于小效应，对吧？品牌认知度，他们为品牌认知度提高1%支付数百万美元。所以如果我们能为科学做到这一点，并说，看，我们运行一个30秒的视频广告活动，我们可以将人们的免疫力提高10%，然后将其扩展
across billions of people, now you could really have something. And so when you talk about herd immunity, that's really the idea, right, that enough people are vaccinated so that misinformation no longer has a chance to spread. And we've done computer simulations of this. And what we find is that it's possible, but there are some caveats. So if you trickle this down into the system where if you have a realistic system where people eventually end up in echo chambers and there's polarization, then springing a little inoculation, you know, at the sort of 10% level, sure, it's beneficial, but it's not going
到数十亿人，现在你真的可以有所作为了。所以当你谈论群体免疫时，这确实是这个想法，对吧，即足够多的人接种了疫苗，以至于错误信息不再有机会传播。我们已经对此进行了计算机模拟。我们发现这是可能的，但有一些注意事项。所以如果你把这个滴入系统中，如果你有一个现实的系统，人们最终进入回声室并且存在两极分化，那么在10%的水平上进行一点接种，当然，它是有益的，但它不会
to move the needle. However, if you front load with a heavy campaign, then actually it can be quite impactful in stopping the flow of information. So acting fast, preemptive, and prophylactic is really key. And so because social media companies control much of the information flow in society, if they were to make this video mandatory in the ad space, so you can't skip it, right? And scale that across billions of people all at once, I think you could really have something in terms of, you know, potential herd immunity. But I will add to that because many people will be skeptical of social media companies and their intentions.
改变现状。然而，如果你用大规模的活动进行预先加载，那么它在阻止信息流方面实际上可以非常有影响力。所以行动迅速、先发制人、预防性是关键。因此，因为社交媒体公司控制了社会中大部分的信息流，如果他们强制在广告空间播放这个视频，这样你就不能跳过它，对吧？并同时将其扩展到数十亿人，我认为你在潜在的群体免疫方面真的可以有所作为。但我会补充一点，因为许多人会对社交媒体公司及其意图持怀疑态度。
And I completely agree. So another route is not to rely on government, not to rely on tech companies, but integrate this into our education, to have a mandate for, you know, to make sure we teach media literacy and even pre-bunking specifically from a very early age to all of our kids in all schools in America and at every year of education to make sure we're boosting, right, to make sure it stays at the design level. And then you can really, you know, by the time we become adults and engage with the stuff, I think you could potentially have a more serious consideration of the concept of herd immunity.
我完全同意。所以另一条途径不是依赖政府，不是依赖科技公司，而是将其整合到我们的教育中，强制要求确保我们从很小的时候起就向美国所有学校的所有孩子教授媒体素养，甚至专门进行预先反驳，并在教育的每一年都这样做，以确保我们正在提升，确保它保持在设计水平。然后你真的可以，到我们成年并接触这些东西时，我认为你可以对群体免疫的概念进行更认真的考虑。
And again, you know, when you do this, I wouldn't say. We need to tell people what they need to believe. I mean, that's not what education is about, but we want to empower people to discern the general techniques of this information, right? Polarizing, you're creating polarizing headlines or false dichotomies, you know, think about if you're pro-Israel, you're anti-Palestine. If you're pro-Palestine, you're anti-Israel. These are misinformation techniques because they take away all nuance and promote extremism, right?
同样，当你这样做时，我不会说我们需要告诉人们他们需要相信什么。我的意思是，教育不是关于那个的，但我们想要赋能人们去辨别错误信息的一般技术，对吧？两极分化，你正在制造两极分化的标题或虚假二分法，你知道，想想如果你是亲以色列的，你就是反巴勒斯坦的。如果你是亲巴勒斯坦的，你就是反以色列的。这些是错误信息技术，因为它们消除了所有细微差别并促进了极端主义，对吧？
So there's a lot of these fallacies out there that are not political. everyone agrees that they're bad, emotional manipulation, that we can teach our kids so that they can build immunity. I want to talk for a minute about generative AI technology, things like chat, GPT. What are the implications of these technologies for the future of misinformation, in your opinion? Do you worry that generative AI is going to accelerate the spread of misinformation by making it so much easier to produce? Yeah. Yeah, so people have divided opinions on this, but I do think that there's both really reasons to be quite concerned, legitimate concern, and also reasons to be optimistic. So I should first preface by saying, you know, I don't, I'm not as alarmed as the people who are panicking about killer robots.
所以有很多这些谬误存在，它们不是政治性的，每个人都同意它们是不好的，情感操纵，我们可以教我们的孩子，这样他们就可以建立免疫力。我想花一分钟谈谈生成式人工智能技术，像ChatGPT这样的东西。在你看来，这些技术对错误信息的未来有什么影响？你是否担心生成式人工智能会通过使生产变得更容易而加速错误信息的传播？是的。是的，所以人们对此有不同的看法，但我确实认为既有非常令人担忧的、合理的担忧，也有乐观的理由。所以我应该首先说明，我不像那些对杀人机器人感到恐慌的人那样感到惊慌。
I think we're a ways away from, you know, starting an army of robots that is going to suppress us. I mean, it's good people think about low probability events in the far future, right? We have to do something as academics. But I'm more concerned about the immediate impact, which is the use of AI in the generation of disinformation. And you see that play out in some really, I think, problematic context. And so one is during elections. Politicians have already used it. We've seen, you know, there was the recent example of Nancy.
我认为我们离启动一支将压制我们的机器人军队还有很长的路要走。我的意思是，人们思考遥远未来的低概率事件是好事，对吧？我们作为学者必须做点什么。但我更担心直接影响，即人工智能在虚假信息生成中的使用。我认为你在一些非常成问题的背景下看到这种情况发生。一个是选举期间。政客们已经使用过它。我们已经看到，最近有南希的例子。
There was a deep fake of her on Facebook that there were. use to take down. Oh, Nancy Pelosi? Yeah, Nancy Pelosi. Yeah. So that's an example. But there was the deep fake of Trump getting arrested before he was actually charged because it plays into people's psychological motivations, right?
脸书上有一个关于她的深度伪造视频，他们使用它来删除。哦，南希·佩洛西？是的，南希·佩洛西。是的。所以这是一个例子。但在特朗普被指控之前，有关于他被捕的深度伪造视频，因为它利用了人们的心理动机，对吧？
So they were expecting this. And so it's easier to manipulate people when they're in a receptive state. But the use of deep fakes in political campaigns is hugely concerning, especially without proper regulation, without social media companies taking this stuff down. I mean, you're really getting into a post. post-truth reality where you can just, you know, create fake images of political opponents and say whatever you will. I mean, this is, I mean, this is concerning. The other part is the microtargeting process. So before, so micro-targeting rights the idea that we can target
所以他们预料到了这一点。因此，当人们处于接受状态时，更容易操纵他们。但在政治竞选中使用深度伪造视频是非常令人担忧的，特别是在没有适当监管、没有社交媒体公司删除这些内容的情况下。我的意思是，你真的进入了一个后真相现实，你可以随意创造政治对手的虚假图像并说任何你想说的话。我的意思是，这令人担忧。另一部分是微目标定位过程。所以之前，微目标定位是我们可以根据人们的个性特征或其他可以通过人们的数字足迹在线抓取的特征来定位
people with messages, fake or real, based on their personality trades or other characteristics that you can scrape online through people's digital footprint, right? So we all have a digital footprint online. We click on website. We like things on social media. of that is data we can gather. And from that data, we can predict what people might want to click on. And so that tremendously enhances the efficiency of targeting and messaging. Also, when that messaging contains propaganda disinformation, but before people had to manually craft these things, right? So you would have to be like, okay, so this person is extroverted or introverted. I'm going to make this fake message appeal to introverts and have a picture of a library with it or something, right?
人们，发送虚假或真实的信息，对吧？所以我们所有人在线上都有数字足迹。我们点击网站。我们在社交媒体上点赞。这些都是我们可以收集的数据。从这些数据中，我们可以预测人们可能想要点击什么。因此，这极大地提高了定位和发送信息的效率。此外，当这些信息包含宣传虚假信息时，但之前人们必须手动制作这些东西，对吧？所以你必须像，好的，这个人是外向的还是内向的。我要让这个虚假信息吸引内向者，并在上面放一张图书馆的照片之类的，对吧？
Whereas the extrovert was just partying and so on. It takes a lot of effort. An AI, chat GPT can do this for you at scale. It can create thousands and thousands of variations of the same message, slightly adapted to different personalities, for example. It can do this very fast. So you don't need people anymore. You could just link the automated generation of accounts with ChadDPT, and you can scale this up. And it empowers really, it democratizes the production of this information.
而外向者只是在聚会等等。这需要付出很多努力。人工智能，ChatGPT可以为你大规模地做到这一点。它可以创建成千上万种相同信息的变体，例如针对不同个性略作调整。它可以非常快地做到这一点。所以你不再需要人了。你只需要将账户的自动生成与ChatGPT链接起来，你就可以扩大规模。它确实赋能了，它使虚假信息的生产民主化了。
And it really allows anyone to now partake in this information war. And so that, you know, even the CEOs of these companies of, you know, Open AI, for example, recognize the threat of AI to the production of this information. On the flip side, it's not all doom and gloom. You can use AI to automate fact-checking. You can use AI to generate prebunks. We've done that. It actually understands prebunking very well.
它确实允许任何人现在参与这场信息战。所以，即使是这些公司的CEO，例如OpenAI，也认识到人工智能对虚假信息生产的威胁。另一方面，这并非全是厄运和阴霾。你可以使用人工智能来自动化事实核查。你可以使用人工智能来生成预先反驳。我们已经做到了。它实际上非常理解预先反驳。
And so I was very surprised. It can generate really good inoculations. It can maybe automatically classify the manipulation techniques that are taking place in online discourse. So we know what the misleading techniques are and how to tackle them. We've even created a test called the Misinformation Susceptibility Test, which is an individual difference sort of test where everyone can take this quick. and get their score back and how kind of naive versus distressful you are and how good you are discerning. But, you know, that test was created by an AI. You know, we had a generate, we trained it on conspiracies and misinformation and it spit out thousands and thousands of fake sounding, but plausible sounding headlines.
所以我非常惊讶。它可以生成非常好的接种材料。它也许可以自动分类在线话语中正在发生的操纵技术。所以我们知道误导性技术是什么以及如何应对它们。我们甚至创建了一个名为“错误信息易感性测试”的测试，这是一种个体差异测试，每个人都可以快速参加，并获得他们的分数，了解你有多天真或多不信任，以及你辨别能力有多好。但是，那个测试是由人工智能创建的。你知道，我们让它生成，我们在阴谋论和错误信息上训练它，它吐出了成千上万个听起来很假，但听起来很合理的标题。
And so we use that in psychological scale development. So I think it's, you know, as a tool, it's neutral. You can use it for bad purposes. You can use it for research purposes. So that's kind of what I'm thinking. But I am concerned about the deployment of it in the context of disinformation. And the political season in the U.S. is already beginning. And I'm just wondering what people can do to recognize that they're being targeted or
因此，我们在心理量表开发中使用了它。所以我认为，作为一个工具，它是中性的。你可以将其用于不良目的，也可以用于研究目的。这就是我的想法。但我确实担心它在虚假信息背景下的部署。美国的政治季已经开始。我只是在想，人们能做些什么来意识到自己正成为目标，或者
micro-targeted, as you said, with false political information. What am I supposed to do as a consumer of news? Yeah. So, you know, one of the things that you can do is to really investigate what information you are disclosing online. So most social media platforms will have some ability for you to look for their sort of transparency statement. Sometimes this can be complex and difficult.
正如你所说的，成为虚假政治信息的微目标。作为新闻消费者，我该怎么办？是的。所以，你可以做的一件事是真正调查你在网上披露了什么信息。大多数社交媒体平台都会让你能够查看它们的透明度声明。有时这可能很复杂且困难。
But basically, you can opt out of a lot of things. So you can opt out of, for example, collecting certain types of data from your feed or your profile. Some social media platforms allow you to curate your own feed. You can opt out of the algorithmic selection, for example. So many people don't realize that on X now, you know, what you see by default is the algorithmically recommended content. But if you click on home timeline, for example, you get what your friends and network are sharing
但基本上，你可以选择退出很多东西。例如，你可以选择退出从你的信息流或个人资料中收集某些类型的数据。一些社交媒体平台允许你策划自己的信息流。例如，你可以选择退出算法选择。很多人没有意识到，在 X 上，你默认看到的是算法推荐的内容。但如果你点击主页时间轴，你就能看到你的朋友和网络正在分享的内容
with you. So most people don't know that what they're seeing is actually the stuff that's recommended based on your click behavior. So I think spending a little bit of time in terms of, you know, becoming cognizant of what you're opting into and what data you're... you're sharing. And then also, you know, becoming aware of some of these techniques that have deployed like trolling, which is very common during elections.
与你分享。所以大多数人不知道他们看到的内容实际上是根据你的点击行为推荐的。所以我认为花一点时间来了解你选择了什么以及你正在分享什么数据是值得的。此外，还要了解一些已经部署的技术，比如在选举期间非常普遍的“钓鱼”（trolling）。
A lot of bots do this. Trolling is a way to bait people and getting them to engage. And you see this typically during elections that flame wars erupt on social media. But people don't often realize that these are either disinformation producers, so real humans or automated accounts that will start an issue. And we worked on this with the State Department. We tried to explain it with something innocent like putting pineapple on pizza. So we said, if you were a troll during an election, how would you disrupt and so chaos
很多机器人都在这样做。钓鱼是一种诱导人们参与的方式。你通常会在选举期间看到社交媒体上爆发口水战。但人们往往没有意识到，这些要么是虚假信息制造者，即真实的人，要么是自动账户，它们会引发争议。我们曾与国务院合作研究过这个问题。我们试图用一些无害的事情来解释它，比如在披萨上放菠萝。所以我们说，如果你是选举期间的喷子，你会如何制造混乱
as a foreign actor, for example? And so, you know, we said, oh, what if you put pineapple on pizza? I mean, that's going to be really offensive to all the American Italians. Italian, what is this? You know, you don't put pineapple on pizza. That's offensive. But then you have the other people who say, this is America, man.
例如，作为一个外国行为者？所以，我们说，如果你在披萨上放菠萝会怎样？我的意思是，这对所有美籍意大利人来说是非常冒犯的。意大利人会说，这是什么？你知道，你不能在披萨上放菠萝。这很冒犯。但随后又有其他人说，这是美国，伙计。
Freedom. I can put on my pizza, whatever I want. Don't, you know, infringing my rights. And then you buy bots to amplify both sides of the debate. And so discourse. Of course, they don't do that with pineapple and pizza. They do it on race, guns, abortion. And so how do you know, right?
自由。我想在我的披萨上放什么就放什么。不要侵犯我的权利。然后你购买机器人来放大辩论的双方。所以话语权。当然，他们不会用菠萝和披萨做这种事。他们会在种族、枪支、堕胎问题上这样做。那么你怎么知道呢，对吧？
So the idea is that if, you know, if you feel that you're being lured into, you know, into saying something about a controversial topic that is provocative, Don't feed the trolls. That's the advice. Don't engage. And yeah, don't be fooled. So that's another way. Just familiarizing yourself with some of these techniques like trolling and false
所以，如果你觉得你被诱导去谈论一个具有挑衅性的争议话题，那么建议就是：不要理会喷子。不要参与。是的，不要被愚弄。所以这是另一种方式。只需让自己熟悉一些这样的技术，比如钓鱼和虚假
economies and scapegoating minority groups. You know, we blame. And we produce materials. People can check out that give easy examples. So, you know, scapegoating typically is where you blame all the problems in society on some group of people. So, you know, during a conflict, it could be Jews, could be Palestinians. But also, you know, so how do you inoculate, for example, against this?
经济以及将少数群体作为替罪羊。你知道，我们责怪。我们制作了人们可以查看的材料，提供简单的例子。所以，替罪羊通常是指你将社会上的所有问题归咎于某一群人。所以，在冲突期间，可能是犹太人，也可能是巴勒斯坦人。但同样，你如何预防这种情况呢？
We give people a clip from South Park where, you know, typically it's the Canadians that are responsible for everything bad in America. Right. It's sort of a funny clip with, oh, Canada. And so that, you know, but it has the same structure. And so it helps people understand. And so, you know, what people can do, and it's one of the most powerful things, is actually help other people spot misinformation.
我们给人们看一段《南方公园》的片段，其中通常是加拿大人对美国发生的一切坏事负责。对吧。这是一个有趣的片段，说着“哦，加拿大”。所以，它有同样的结构。这有助于人们理解。所以，人们能做的，也是最强大的事情之一，实际上是帮助其他人识别错误信息。
I think for true herd immunity, in fact, what we need is for it to spread from person to person. So that's the beautiful thing. I think about the psychological vaccine that you don't have with the biological vaccine. You can't really share your biological vaccine with people, but you can't share the psychological vaccine. It's what we call post-inoculation discourse or talk. And so you can actually then explain it to other people and pay it forward. And that's how we protect each other. So that's another way of not only paying it forward.
我认为要实现真正的群体免疫，实际上我们需要它在人与人之间传播。这就是心理疫苗的美妙之处，这是生物疫苗所不具备的。你无法真正与他人分享你的生物疫苗，但你可以分享心理疫苗。这就是我们所说的接种后话语或谈话。因此，你实际上可以向其他人解释它并传递下去。这就是我们保护彼此的方式。所以这是不仅传递下去的另一种方式。
We also find that when you do that, you're kind of rehearsing. and boosting yourself in the process. So it has, it has, you know, various benefits. Now, the mainstream media seem to be one place where you can often get the most reliable information, but I'm just wondering if they're doing a better or a worse job of fact-checking now that this has become so prevalent. I mean, are they really alerting their readers, their listeners, their viewers to false information? Yeah, I think traditional media, I think people often forget. They often say the so different about social media. I think a huge difference is that on social media,
我们还发现，当你这样做时，你实际上是在排练，并在过程中加强自己。所以它有各种好处。现在，主流媒体似乎是一个你通常可以获得最可靠信息的地方，但我只是想知道，既然这种情况变得如此普遍，他们是否在事实核查方面做得更好或更差。我的意思是，他们真的在提醒他们的读者、听众和观众注意虚假信息吗？是的，我认为传统媒体，人们经常忘记。他们经常说社交媒体有什么不同。我认为一个巨大的区别是，在社交媒体上，
there's no barrier to entry. You can upload any content. There's no editorial process. There are no fact checkers. There's no attention to accuracy at all. People can say whatever they want. With traditional media, you at least have an editor. You have fact checkers in most places. You have journalistic standards. You have regulatory bodies. So there's a lot of steps that prevent traditional media from just saying crazy things. Of course, things get a little bit muddled when you go to cable and streaming and so on. But in the most traditional form, there's actually a big difference in the curation of it. I think most fact checkers are doing their best to keep up with the scale of the problem. I agree with you that traditional media is
没有准入门槛。你可以上传任何内容。没有编辑过程。没有事实核查员。根本不关注准确性。人们可以随心所欲地说任何话。在传统媒体中，你至少有一位编辑。大多数地方都有事实核查员。你有新闻标准。你有监管机构。所以有很多步骤可以防止传统媒体胡说八道。当然，当你转向有线电视和流媒体等时，事情会变得有点混乱。但在最传统的形式中，内容策划确实有很大的不同。我认为大多数事实核查员都在尽最大努力跟上问题的规模。我同意你的观点，传统媒体
not doing enough to warn people in advance and equipping them with the tools to discern misinformation better. And they could do a lot more. We could do a lot more in in podcasts and movies on news channels. And so, you know, it's all about, you know, when people watch TV, that's an opportunity, you know, in some way, in a lot of ways to learn about, you know, some of the techniques that are used to produce misinformation, how to look out for them. And that's, it's often done online, but people kind of forget about the power of regularly
在提前警告人们并为他们提供辨别错误信息的工具方面做得不够。他们可以做得更多。我们可以在播客、电影和新闻频道中做得更多。所以，这一切都是关于，当人们看电视时，这是一个机会，在某种程度上，在很多方面了解一些用于制造错误信息的技术，以及如何防范它们。这通常是在网上完成的，但人们有点忘记了定期
media. Most people watch TV, right? And so that's, you know, that's a powerful avenue. Podcasts also hugely unexplored. I mean, that's online. But the amount of people who are tuning in the podcasts, you know, think about Andrew Tate, Joe Rogan sort of stuff, you know, it's, again, it's all unverified. There's very little regulation. But podcasts are also a tool to engage with people.
媒体的力量。大多数人看电视，对吧？所以这是一个强大的途径。播客也极其未被开发。我的意思是，那是在线。但收听播客的人数，想想安德鲁·泰特（Andrew Tate）、乔·罗根（Joe Rogan）之类的东西，你知道，这再次是未经证实的。几乎没有监管。但播客也是与人互动的一种工具。
And so, yeah, there's a lot of new ways, I think, to help prepare people. And I would say that traditional media, although they have this sort of base level of protection, they're not being very proactive about educating citizens. I just want to say that this podcast stands by truth when we're not spreading misinformation here. Very good. So what are the next big questions that you're trying to answer? What are you working on right now? Yeah. So, you know, some of the big questions are, you know, how can you sort of test these things in a large population scale RCT?
所以，是的，我认为有很多新方法可以帮助人们做好准备。我想说的是，传统媒体虽然有这种基础水平的保护，但他们在教育公民方面并不积极。我只想说，这个播客坚持真相，我们在这里不传播错误信息。非常好。那么你试图回答的下一个大问题是什么？你现在在研究什么？是的，一些大问题是，你如何在大规模人群随机对照试验（RCT）中测试这些东西？
You know, when you think about the best available evidence for interventions, you want to roll it out kind of like a medical trial, right? And so it's very challenging to get actual behavioral data from people. For example, what websites might people be visiting, right, after they've learned about these things? What videos are they watching? Their privacy concerns, right? But social media companies also often don't share that data. So when we run a campaign and find that, yeah, we've inoculated people and they're now better at spotting these techniques, you know, are they also watching less misinformation online on the platform? They won't share that type of behavioral data.
当你考虑干预措施的最佳可用证据时，你会想把它像医学试验一样推广，对吧？因此，从人们那里获得实际的行为数据是非常具有挑战性的。例如，人们在了解这些事情后可能会访问哪些网站？他们正在看什么视频？他们的隐私问题，对吧？但社交媒体公司通常也不会分享这些数据。所以当我们开展一项活动并发现我们已经为人们接种了疫苗，他们现在更擅长识别这些技术时，他们是否也在平台上减少了观看错误信息？他们不会分享那种行为数据。
If we do an experiment, let's say, you know, offline, how do you measure how much misinformation people are spreading interpersonally with other people? You know, these are very difficult things to measure and quantify. So we're trying to think hard about how can we establish, you know, the same level of evidence as you would for a public health type of intervention. And that's kind of also what we talk about a little in the report. about missing links is the link to, you know, the causal impact of misinformation. So the flip side is, you know, I was talking about protecting people, but the flip side is actually the causal
如果我们做一个实验，比如说，在线下，你如何衡量人们在人际间传播了多少错误信息？这些是非常难以衡量和量化的事情。所以我们正在努力思考我们如何才能建立与公共卫生干预措施相同水平的证据。这也是我们在报告中谈到的一点。关于缺失的环节，是与错误信息的因果影响的联系。所以反面是，我刚才谈到了保护人们，但反面实际上是错误信息的因果
impact of misinformation. We know that misinformation can kill people, but actually it's almost impossible to study the circumstances under which that happens. You know, we don't have access to working with people who are refusing COVID treatment and might even die from COVID because they believe in conspiracy theories, right? We typically, you know, people who believe in conspiracies typically don't want to participate in scientific research. And so, you know, and how do you know for sure that it's one piece of information that is the causal agent in people's behavior?
影响。我们知道错误信息可以杀人，但实际上几乎不可能研究这种情况发生的具体环境。我们无法接触到那些拒绝新冠治疗甚至可能因相信阴谋论而死于新冠的人，对吧？我们通常认为，相信阴谋论的人通常不想参与科学研究。那么，你怎么能确定某一条信息就是人们行为的因果因素呢？
Behavior is very complex. So how do you isolate it? These are very tough questions that I think we need to do more research on. Obviously, AI, deep fakes, right? How would you, how would you inoculate people against manipulated images? is the next question. But also, who's the right disseminator of this stuff? I mean, some people, you know, we have to think about power relations, right?
行为非常复杂。那么你如何将其隔离出来？我认为这些是非常棘手的问题，我们需要做更多的研究。显然，人工智能、深度伪造（deep fakes），对吧？你将如何为人们接种疫苗以抵御被操纵的图像？这是下一个问题。但同样，谁是这些东西的正确传播者？我的意思是，有些人，我们必须考虑权力关系，对吧？
So some people perceive the government as a powerful actor that's suppressing certain communities, right? Some people think of public health organizations in the same way. Who should be the arbiter of truth? Who should be the communicator of information? I think increasingly realizing that maybe actually relying on trusted community leaders could be a good way to diffuse accurate information into the population. So people might not listen to the government, but maybe they'll listen to their local rabbi or imam or a religious leader, right? Or maybe an influencer. That can also go sideways when influencers are spreading conspiracy theories.
所以有些人认为政府是一个压制某些社区的强大行为者，对吧？有些人以同样的方式看待公共卫生组织。谁应该是真理的仲裁者？谁应该是信息的传播者？我认为越来越意识到，也许依靠值得信赖的社区领袖可能是将准确信息传播到人群中的好方法。所以人们可能不会听政府的，但也许他们会听当地的拉比、伊玛目或宗教领袖，对吧？或者也许是一个有影响力的人。当有影响力的人传播阴谋论时，这也可能适得其反。
But sometimes they have what if Taylor Swift was. announcing, you know, highly factual information to the world on a regular basis. What would the world look like with her platform, right? And so we're thinking of new ideas of, you know, who are our good spokespeople for this issue? Is it the APA, right? Maybe APA has a role to play. And so that's, you know, that's currently what we're thinking about testing also, like
但有时他们有，如果泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）会怎样？定期向世界宣布高度真实的信息。拥有她的平台，世界会是什么样子，对吧？所以我们正在考虑新的想法，谁是我们这个问题的良好代言人？是美国心理学会（APA）吗？也许 APA 可以发挥作用。所以这就是我们目前正在考虑测试的内容，比如
who's the right communicator. Well, Dr. Vanderlind, and I want to thank you for joining me today. I think you've given us a lot to think about. My pleasure. Thanks so much for having me on the show on the great questions. Okay. And I want to let our listeners know that this great report that APA did with the great help and leadership of Dr. Vanderlin is available on our website at APA.org.
谁是正确的传播者。好吧，范德林德（Vanderlind）博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。我认为你给了我们很多思考的空间。我的荣幸。非常感谢邀请我参加节目，提出了很棒的问题。好的。我想让我们的听众知道，APA 在范德林德博士的伟大帮助和领导下完成的这份精彩报告可以在我们的网站 APA.org 上找到。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以通过 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 给我们发电子邮件。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。